lisa how are you good i like your
background
this is a a picture of my backyard well
that's nice
yeah cause otherwise let me show you
what you'd be dealing with
okay let's see it i wanna and i dressed
it this is what's sad
it's a beige maybe i'll put some flowers
make it pretty it looks like you're
visiting your great aunt
that's what it looks like come on is
there plastic on the furniture
on the cover so here's what i've been
thinking about preparing to talk to you
which is i've known you for a long time
and you are the person who i would say
has been preparing for this
pandemic since the day i met you
i you've just you are someone who uh
first of all you studied
biology at chemistry biochemistry
seriously
yeah seriously you always used to be
telling me over the years a pandemic
could be coming
and you like to hunker down now it's
happening
are you adjusting adjusting there was no
adjusting
it was just this is how i lived my life
there were days and days where i just
never even left my house or went into my
car
this is the question a lot of couples
are up against
your significant other you and michelle
yeah how are you guys doing
in this lockdown are you getting along
what's really working is he's mostly
in living in another city right now so
that's
the truth yeah where is michelle
he's in the desert well he's here now
but he spends a lot of time in the
desert
spends a lot of time in the desert it
sounds like he's roaming around
no he sounds like jesus
sounds like moses just wandering around
does he come back spiritually
enlightened when he goes when he's
wandering in the desert
for like 30 days he's 400 years old
[Laughter]
are you good at this zoom thing i've
gotten a little bit better at it
yeah i did i think i got pretty good at
it
and then um i thought i got pretty good
at it and then i had a board meeting
for you know i'm at vassar you're on the
board
at vassar college your alma mater yes i
knew that and
and by the way it was my very last board
meeting
i don't know why i could attend because
i didn't have to
go there um but at the very last one and
that's a very big deal it's been 16
years
you've been on the board at vassar
college for 16 years
yes because i go to have your last
meeting that's got to be a little
emotional and it's on zoom
and it's on zoom but i think they said
they were going to sort of carve out
time because usually at the
when you're there there's a dinner and
you you know say goodbye with a
meaningful speech something you know so
i was thinking about you know what i was
going to say
and then out of nowhere it felt it was
okay so this is
lisa's last meeting we know she's got to
go
so early so and i and i just went oh no
i don't have to go early
and nothing's happening the president of
the school is starting to address me
president bradley and i'm like no i
don't have to go oh i'm on mute okay
no i don't have to go she's still not
doesn't seem to hear me i'm like
i don't have to go i don't have to go
but they can't hear you because i didn't
press it
oh no i'm trying to listen i've missed
everything she said
other than and i'm talking to her and i
said oh my god i'm talking to phoebe
and i went really that's how i came off
like
someone who doesn't know what evolution
is like
and then it just seemed like all right
well so you have a lot to do
and we have a lot to do of course they
have a lot to do in the middle of all
this
so thank you lisa and i just went
okay well bye and hung up
so what someone there texted me and just
wrote
boo